and then you guys can just like i guess
choose who had like the most
entertaining story and they only had 90
seconds to share it go
hey bobby kalila george um
gilbert uh so my story valentine's story
is was the reason why i think i hate
valentine's day
um so i was like 22 years old
um fell in love with this one girl and i
went to go
buy her a like a watch with a diamond on
it you know it's like the first diamond
that i've ever
bought in my life so um you know i'm all
excited i got get to the store
and you know i'm pretty jazzed about it
and then i come to find out on
valentine's day when i give it to her
that she cheated on me
and we broke up on valentine's day
so and the worst part was is that when i
went back to the store to return it
and i was just like devastated
i went to go return it and then the same
lady that sold me the watch
was uh the person taking the return and
she was just like oh she didn't like it
i was like bawling in front of this
place oh
um but yeah that was my valentine's day
i thought i thought the story was going
to go
and the same lady said no refunds
[Laughter]
i told you i told you already you know i
mean no reason
stop crying yeah so what
to me that's a happy story because at
least he got his money back
yeah went back and you dodged a cheater
right dodged a cheater
right and um that that was a happy story
yeah yeah have any of you guys been
cheated on
have you ever been cheated on i don't
think he ever has i don't think he's
ever been dumped or do you secretly
think you are so you immediately end the
relationship yourself
because you're like quick like that i
don't think i care
oh well that's not good either yeah yeah
i think you're supposed to care about
the relationship here
i don't think i would care yeah i don't
think i don't care
we i we have been him and i have been
rejected a lot
but i don't think i i've been cheated on
but i've never been dumped
i just cheated on valentine's day mm-hmm
we have one more because if i would no
disappoint back up
so let's think about a relationship i
was in
oh yeah so one time i was dating this
girl named amy
poor george has to keep bleeping and
and i was
flying to italy or something for
something
not italy france to shoot up ibm
commercial
and i remember i was at a bar
with a bunch of people and i turn around
and i look down this
alleyway and i see
a guy holding amy's hand and she's like
pushing away
and he's doing like you know like doing
this like caressing and she's like kind
of like
moving away from him like this yeah yeah
and i thought
i remember just feeling joy that it was
over oh
why when she didn't do anything wrong
but you could tell that she was with
this guy
oh no oh too why'd you feel joy
i don't know let's go in the next video
you're going to dislike that i remember
this story about you and her that you
told me
okay you were about to leave for france
or germany or wherever the hell that ibm
commercial was
and it was your final night together and
um
you went to dinner with your manager and
your age
and you didn't invite her and she she
cried okay
so here's what happened okay this is the
truth and i i'm so
i'm so [ __ ] the bum that you even
remember that
so now i have to and i have to redo this
story
so hold on a second okay so what
happened was
i booked this ibm commercial and i go
i'm gonna have a dinner with my agent
and my manager
i didn't invite amy okay which was the
wrong thing to do
right and i wasn't leaving for another
couple weeks
right so and then two weeks later right
before i'm gonna go
i went to her one man one woman show or
something right
and it wasn't at a bar it was at that
show where i turned the corner and she
had
because i didn't invite her to you know
i
mean
the dinner with my manager agent she
drifted apart
from there and then she met a guy right
and i caught her with that guy wait you
weren't officially over yet
no it was one of those things that we
were sleeping together and all that
stuff but we
wouldn't really talk about what we
really were oh then you could didn't
have to invite her to dinner then if she
wasn't no
at that point i should have because we
were on an item
okay you're being a little bit with
fuckboy and vague with your answers were
you or were you not was it just a
situation
next video happy valentine's day
happy valentine's day i would say about
two years ago wait this guy looks like
me
playing the same nose a surprise la trip
for valentine's day